nos dicen cuenta de 10 en 10 hacia atrás
empezando en 750 llena los espacios en
blanco iniciamos con 750 y como estamos
contando de 10 en 10 hacia atrás a este
750 vamos a restarle 10 750 menos 10 sí
tenemos aquí un 5 en el lugar de las
decenas pues le restamos un 1 ya que es
una decena a este 55 menos 1 es 4 así
que tendremos 744 en el lugar de las
decenas ahora a este 740 hay que
restarle 10 nos fijamos en el número que
está en la posición de las escenas que
es este 4 y este 4 le voy a restar una
decena le voy a restar 10 4 - 1 es 3
ahora tengo 730 tengo el 3 en la
posición de las decenas por lo que reste
10 una decena a esta cantidad
ahora el número que sigue ya está 720
que es 730 menos 10 720 lo que es lo
mismo a este 3 en la posición de las
escenas quitarle un 1 una decena 3 - 1
es 2 aquí lo tenemos no lo tenemos que
escribir y ahora lo que sigue 720 menos
10 que es lo mismo que 720 menos una
decena tenemos aquí dos escenas dos
escenas menos una decenas son 1 710 con
el 1 en la posición de las escenas ahora
el último número a este número hay que
quitarle 10 una decena tenemos aquí
justamente en la posición de las escenas
un 11 menos 1 va a ser cero aquí vamos a
tener 700 comprobamos respuesta es
correcta hagamos otro problema ahora nos
dice en cuenta de 10 en 10 empezando en
825 tenemos que ir agregando porque nos
dicen que empecemos en 825
los espacios en blanco ok tenemos 825
ahora a esto hay que agregarle 10 una
decena nos fijamos qué número hay en la
posición de las escenas y hay un 2 a
este 2 ahora le vamos a agregar un 1 una
decena va a ser 32 más 13 por lo que
escribimos 83 en la posición de las
escenas y seguimos con las mismas cinco
unidades 835 lo que sigue hacemos lo
mismo ahora a este tres de las decenas
le vamos a agregar una decena más 314
tendremos ocho centenas cuatro decenas
cinco unidades nos fijamos en el
siguiente número y vemos que en el lugar
de las escenas tiene cinco de la
anterior
las escenas teníamos 44 más unas cuatro
decenas más una decena nos dan cinco
decenas ahora a partir de éste tenemos
que agregarle diez más
tenemos 5 decenas más una decena más son
8 centenas 6 56 decenas y 5 unidades el
último número ahora a estas seis decenas
les agregamos una decena más 6 más 17 en
la última cantidad es 8 centenas siete
decenas y cinco unidades comprobamos la
respuesta es correcta